[MUSIC PLAYING]
Good afternoon, everybody,
and welcome to today's Wiesner
gallery online tour.
My name is Shannon
Rose McAuliffe,
and I'm the manager of
the student arts programs
here at MIT.
I'm joined by
Sarah Hirzel, she's
the coordinator of the
Wiesner student art gallery
and Elaheh Ahmadi, who is
an interdisciplinary artist
from Tehran, Iran.
[INAUDIBLE]
Elaheh is a 2020 graduate
of MIT in the Department
of Electrical Engineering
and Computer Science.
And she's currently
a graduate student
in that very same program.
She learned photography as
an undergraduate student
in the Department of arts,
culture, and technology.
Elaheh's project
has been sponsored
by the Council for the Arts
at MIT, also known as CAMIT.
And after a brief
introduction by Sarah Herzl
about the exhibition,
Elaheh will lead us
through the virtual show
via her screen share.
You're welcome to
view the exhibition
on her website, which
is going to be put
into the chat on your Sidebar.
After this tour please
feel free to join us
for some question and answers.
Feel free to submit your
questions using the chat box,
use the Raise Hand
function and we'll
open the floor for some
really lovely discussion.
And without further
ado, before we begin,
my friend Sarah has
a couple of words.
Thank you so much, Shannon
Rose, for everything.
It has been a sincere
pleasure working with Elaheh
on this exhibition.
I want to extend my
particular thanks
to Heidi Erickson, our graphic
designer and web creator
for MIT'S office of the arts.
We are grateful for
the generous support
of many members of the
staff of the Office
of the arts and CAMIT.
Before we begin, I
want to acknowledge
how Elaheh beautifully
demonstrates the importance
of the arts at MIT.
Her subjects are
very representative
of the creativity and
depth of our community.
Elaheh is not just
a photographer.
She is something
of a documentarian
and a social artist for whom
interpersonal connection
has high creative value.
She invites her participants
and her audience
to bring their full selves into
the communities they study,
live, and play in.
Nurturing the success
of women and others
in settings such as
MIT is important work.
And it's exciting that Elaheh
can use the art of photography
to tell stories that allow
for openness and connection.
She uses her own challenges
to nurture others.
And as many of her
collaborators will attest,
she is a joy to work with.
I am very pleased to
introduce Elaheh Ahmadi.
Woo hoo!
Thank you, Sarah and Shannon
for the amazing introduction
and organizing this event.
I'm so happy this is
finally happening.
I'm so excited that all
of you could join us
for the opening of
this exhibition.
This project has been
a huge part of my life
for the past three years and
I'm so excited to finally share
the result with all of you.
I have put together a video
about the journey of Trapped
and I don't want
to spoil the rest.
So let's just watch it,
I hope you all enjoy it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Welcome to Trapped
exhibition, virtually
hosted by Wiesner
gallery at MIT.
My name is a Elaheh and I
am the director of Trapped.
This project
started in fall 2018
as a final project for my
intro to photography class,
taught by Laura [INAUDIBLE].
At that time, I was
dealing with a lot
of challenges in
my personal life
that led me to a
very dark place.
But I found photography and
darkroom to be my saviors.
In the class, Trapped started
with me expressing how
I was feeling at the moment.
Trapped by all the
society's expectations.
All the laws that kept
me from seeing my family.
The pressure of being
a female in engineering
and having to suppress
my femininity.
And being trapped in a
relationship that getting out
of it meant being a failure.
So I asked a friend
or two to be my model
and help me capture my feelings.
I showed the first couple
of photos to Laura,
and she told me, this doesn't
have to be just about you.
It can be about all women.
I'll give you another week
and go see where this goes.
I am so grateful she said that
because if it wasn't for her,
I wouldn't have had the courage
to ask people to take time out
of their lives to
just model for me.
But I gave it a shot, I started
opening up to my friends,
telling them how I
was feeling and little
did I know that I wasn't alone.
From my friends back home, to my
close friends and peers at MIT.
To people I just met
at a bar or party.
We all felt trapped,
one way or another.
And it was then
that I realized, I
need to let people know
how we, women, are feeling.
I need to take a
step into creating
a safe space for everyone
to be able to share
their experiences.
And for others to ask
questions about it.
I believe that talking about the
issues and letting others know
is a good step toward creating
a society that treats everyone
equally.
So I did.
I made Trapped to be
the voice of all women
from all backgrounds.
The process would usually
start with a conversation
in some setting.
And someone would either
show interest in the project
or I would think of an
idea or two for the person.
And I would propose them
to collaborate with me.
Before each photo shoot, I
would tell my participant
to wear whatever they want,
it just has to be all black.
And then after what I would call
a heart to heart conversation,
about our challenges, the
photo shoot would happen.
Each photo shoot was unique.
Sometimes I would
find a place on campus
or I would go to their houses
or we would just go to streets.
And sometimes it just
happened at the moment.
And suddenly I had
the perfect shot.
But the photo shoot
wasn't just about that.
It was about the
whole experience.
Me, letting myself to be
vulnerable around my female
and non binary peers.
Them appreciating my
honesty and also opening up
about their experience.
And us connecting
on a deeper level.
And then we would throw
ideas off of each other
until we were happy with a shot.
Once the photo
shoot was over, it
was time for
post-processing the images.
I use both digital
and 35 millimeter
film to shoot the photos.
I would spend hours in
a darkroom developing
and printing the photos
or in the digital lab
doing some minor edits
and printing the photos.
One of the most rewarding
parts of the process
was bringing the moments I had
with the participants to life
through the photos.
This project not only helped me
to get through the hard times,
but it also helped many
of the participants
to start being more
vocal and expressive
with the challenges they're
dealing with on a daily basis.
One of my participants posted
the photos on her Instagram
and she came out to
her family and friends
about her open
marriage and sexuality.
Which it made me
so happy and proud
to get to be apart of that.
The project grew not
because I was pushing it,
but because our voices
through the photos
were so powerful that it
made people feel safe to open
up and talk about it.
All of it.
How our communities we grew up
in suffered from gender bias.
How gender bias affected
our life choices.
How we felt shut down in
meetings and projects.
How we felt judged by the
way we dress or by our body.
After 16 unique photo
shoots with different women,
I decided in February
2020 that I was
ready to wrap up the project.
So I called in
all the people who
participated before, all the
people who showed interest
at any time, for a
final group photo shoot.
I gave them the same
instructions, told all of them
that you need to
wear something black,
whatever you are
comfortable with.
Put on as much makeup as you
want or don't, do your hair
or don't, just show
up with something
that you're comfortable with,
something that is in you.
So I told everybody to
show up at 10 AM Saturday.
This was different from
all the photo shoots
that I did before because
it wasn't a one on one.
Something that I was
like comfortable with
and it was a comfortable
intimate setup.
It was a group
setting that everybody
from different backgrounds,
I asked all of them
to get together.
So before that all
of the photo shoots,
I didn't planned
them much beforehand.
Because I knew once
we get into it,
we will throw ideas
off of each other
and the photo shoot
would just happen.
But this one was different.
So what I did was I took all
of the prints that I had,
my camera, all the
set up, just showed up
where it was
supposed to show up.
And you should have been there.
It was amazing.
Just seeing all these awesome,
beautiful, smart, strong women
get together in this set.
And most of them didn't
even know other people.
Maybe every person knew
one or two other person.
But for a lot of them It
was a an uncomfortable setup
too because nobody did
modeling professionally.
It was something
new for all of them.
But we all shared one thing, and
it was we believed in Trapped.
We believed that
Trapped is something
that can help all of
us voice our feelings,
our struggles and that was
what brought everybody together
on that day.
And it was amazing.
So at the beginning
of the session,
I put all the prints
down and I told
everybody take whatever
print that you feel close to
and write something
on the back of it
or draw something or do
whatever you feel comfortable.
Something like if that
photo spoke to you
and that's why you picked it,
then you have something to say.
And that was for me to just get
everybody in that head space
and also have some time
to put prepare the setup.
And the results
were just fabulous.
To see how other
people felt something
with somebody else, who
maybe was from another world,
was born somewhere else,
had a completely different
background, but there was
still one connection there.
In my opinion that was the
best way to warm up everybody.
Let everybody to be
comfortable, loosen up,
and get to that head space.
And we started shooting.
We started taking
the group photos.
You can see them now
in the exhibition.
I love them.
I mean I'm biased, but I
think they look amazing.
Just seeing everybody's
beautiful faces,
the different outfits, the
different way that they
put themselves in the frame.
I didn't tell them what to do.
All I told them was exist.
Do whatever feels
comfortable for you.
If that means talking with
somebody else that you know,
do that.
I don't care.
I want you to be in the
head space you are now
and express yourself
somehow with your body.
And I couldn't believe it
when I looked at my watch
and it was four PM and I was
shooting six hours nonstop.
I think for me that was one
of the best days I've ever
had doing anything.
Six hours not even
realizing how time passed.
And I was happy, just jumping
everywhere and looking
at the photos, loving everything
that was happening there.
And it was amazing
to see I wasn't
the only one enjoying myself.
Other people were
also really enjoying
talking to other people, getting
each other's contact info,
just connecting
and networking too.
And it was the best way
to wrap up this project
because that was what I wanted.
I wanted to bring
people together.
I wanted to create a safe space.
And I wanted people
to see other women,
realize they're not alone,
and be proud of the struggles
and how far they came.
And even though most of the
times everything is against us.
Hi, I'm Alexa.
I'm from San Francisco and
I graduated MIT last year
in Core 6-2.
I'm currently a program
manager in camera and depth
hardware in the Bay Area.
I had the honor and privilege of
doing a photo shoot for Trapped
with Elaheh.
The photo shoot was such
an awesome experience.
It was a glimpse into the crazy,
creative mind that is Elaheh.
We were just bouncing
ideas off of each other.
What if you blur
this with motion?
What if you put this
pattern on your face?
What if you turned around?
It was all these what
ifs flying around
and I think part of the
reason it was so easy
and fun is because she's
my really good friend
and it was a really comfortable
space for experimentation.
And I think the other part
of it is because she's
such a great photographer.
And she turns the world into
her art so effortlessly.
I think Trapped as
a whole is a set
of feelings and emotions to me.
It's isolation, despair,
and hopelessness.
It's this feeling of being
where you don't want to be
and not knowing how to get out.
I think that's
somewhere that we've all
been to a certain extent.
I think that's also the reason
why this project expanded
to what it is now.
It's because the theme is so
universal yet also so personal
to each individual.
Thanks Elaheh for letting
me be a part of this
and I hope everyone enjoys
it as much as I did.
Hi, my name is Ellie.
I was born in Iran
and raised in the US.
I currently live in
Los Angeles, California
and I graduated from
Boston University in 2020.
I was part of the
Trapped photo shoot
and I'm extremely grateful that
I was a part of the Trapped
photo shoot because it just
means so many different things
to me.
As a young girl growing
up in Iran and the US
and hearing from all
different types of people,
how women should feel
and how they should look
and how they should act
and how they should react.
And then thinking that's not how
I look, that's not how I feel,
that's not how I want to act
or react to certain situations.
And just this Trapped
project was a way for me
to be able to of break down
some of those stereotypes
and show how I am
and what I feel.
The photo shooting process was
something completely new to me
and Elaheh is an
amazing photographer.
And she made me feel so
comfortable the entire time.
As someone who doesn't always
like how she looks in pictures
and always picks out her flaws,
the way that the pictures came
out and just the entire
process, it was amazing.
And I just felt so comfortable
and confident and beautiful
in those pictures even
that's not how I always feel.
The final photo shoot was
definitely my favorite.
Seeing this beautiful
group of women
of all different backgrounds
and ages and cultures
coming together as the
culmination of this Trapped
project.
And just seeing what
Trapped meant to them,
and hearing their stories,
and their backgrounds.
And sharing my story it was
just so empowering and amazing.
And I am extremely
grateful to have
been a part of this project.
And it really does mean
a lot to a lot of people.
And now today, I am so proud
to present you the Trapped
exhibition.
A project that
would have not been
possible without
every single person
supporting me, and pushing me,
motivating me to move forward.
It was an honor to work with
all these amazing people who
worked on this project with me.
And to create a project
that will hopefully
give some people courage
to speak up and be
who they want to be and do
what their heart desires.
And now the moment we've all
been waiting for, or at least
I have, is finally here.
I would like to welcome you
to the exhibition of Trapped.
The first thing you will see
as you walk into the exhibition
is the photo of a person in
their most vulnerable position.
Surrounded by a light
where there is nothing
but darkness at the outside.
I see this photo
as a great opener
for what you're about
to experience as you
walk through the exhibition.
Then if you scroll
down, you will
find a description
of the project
and what you're
about to experience
and how you can experience
this exhibition.
If you scroll down
more, you can then
find the name, a photo, and a
bio of different participants.
You can scroll to see who
different participants are,
where they're coming from, what
their story is, how they felt
and relate to this project.
And you can then
see their experience
by clicking on this button.
If you scroll down
more, you can then
find a video of me telling you
about how this project started
and series of the
group photo shoots
and the lists of the names
of all the peoples who
contributed to this project.
And then there's
a Navigator that
can help you navigate
to different walls
of the exhibition.
Now let's go and see
Alexa's experience.
When you enter the
participants wall,
you can see all of their photos
by clicking right and left
into this slider.
You can then scroll down
and see their walls,
where you can find their
bio and all of their photos
next to each other.
Some photos have reflections,
which are in the form of poetry
or a short essay, mixed photos.
These reflections are
written by other artist.
You can also click on the
photos and see them isolated.
Once you've enjoyed that
participants' wall you can then
navigate to see the next
participants' Please make sure
you visit all the different
walls and see where all these
amazing people are coming
from, what is their story,
and how they relate
to Trapped project.
At any time, if you want to
go back to the exhibition
main page, you can
just click here
and that will take you
to the opening page.
Or as I would like to
call it the opening wall.
In the end, I want
to thank all of you
for joining me today
for this opening.
I also want to
thank everyone who
participated in this
project one way or another
I want to thank [INAUDIBLE]
for designing the exhibition.
And also my amazing
professors and mentors
Laura and [INAUDIBLE] for
helping me, mentoring me,
and guiding me
through this journey.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[INAUDIBLE]
I want you to just
do this, exactly.
I feel like the
ivory [INAUDIBLE]
[MUSIC - BILLIE EILISH, "BURY A
FRIEND"]
(SINGING) Expensive.
It's probably something that
shouldn't be said out loud.
Honestly I thought that
I would be dead by now.
Wow.
Calling security Keeping
my head held down.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[NON ENGLISH SPEECH]
Elsa but you look so cute.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
Thank you for watching it.
Wow, I tried so hard not to cry.
The behind the scene helped.
Now I want to jump start
the Q&A by asking you
a question from one of the
amazing participants who
could make it here today.
Dodo, I'm so glad you
I have a question for you.
I was wondering
if you could share
your experience with Trapped and
how your photos made you feel.
Yeah, of course.
I was watching, in
the video, where
some of the other
participants shared as well.
So, I'll try to live up
to that level of insight.
So, yeah, thank you
for inviting me.
This has really been
a journey for you
and all the participants.
I know for myself,
actually, it's
a journey that started very
early when I was much younger.
And Trapped very promptly at
the time, a couple of years ago,
helped me put words to
it, to put an image to it.
And then something that
continues after Trapped, I
think for my own reflection
to grow after that.
So I'm very happy to
see you again and also
share that with everyone here.
So first off, I guess
the experience itself
I would say it was very
fun and reflective.
Fun being that from
the video, I think
everybody saw that it was a
very collaborative process.
I didn't feel like I was
the model doing whatever
Elaheh wanted me to do.
That was not the
point of the project.
So I think you, Elaheh,
very intentionally
wanted it to be a
thought partnership
and play around with it, like
it's a true collaboration.
So I love that we were
just experimenting,
the idea of having makeup.
It was when we were talking at
some point, I don't even know,
I don't even remember
who popped up the idea,
but you know we went with it
and it turned out really well.
So yeah, the whole experience
itself I think has a lot of fun
to it.
But of course at the same time I
think because of your outreach,
it's helped me really start
to reflect on this feeling
that I've had for
a really long time.
And personally, I
was also the girl
in tech, or math,
very, very early on.
I went through this whole
competitive math track,
came from China to US for
high school, and then MIT.
And on top of all that,
I also reflected myself
to be an artist at heart
who's studying engineering
at MIT, who has an interest
in business, who growing up
in a society where I had a
lot of expectations of women
not necessarily in
tech, or math, or art.
So I felt like
through the project
I was able to really see it
through the power of arts
in one, two, three
images and a couple
short blurbs what this
conflict has been about.
And I think the
point that it was
the struggle between
the outside expectations
and my own way of
looking at myself.
The multiple identities that
could exist in the same person,
but we live in a world
of specialization.
We live in the world of putting
a single label on people.
But in fact, I felt like I'm
much more than a single label.
I'm much more than a
specialized career.
I'm much more than
any part of me.
So thank you for jump
starting that reflection.
I would say that
reflection actually
since college has really in the
past two or three years since I
started working, so I
worked for about three years
at a global consulting
firm, I just
recently decided to change my
career into k-12 education,
also professional coaching.
And I think actually
this whole reflection
of who I really
am, who I can be,
all the different parts of
me, really led me here, right.
I think just even in my
previous career as a consultant,
I was continuing to reflect on
how those outside expectations
of what you should behave,
what you should like.
Your job title becomes
your only identity.
And I was actually
very happy that I
could be bring this discussion
to my colleagues, to my team,
to the company itself.
We actually had a discussion
around multiple identity.
How people see themselves
versus what they think the job
requires them to be perceived.
And these discussions
continue and I
think if I were to sum up of
how I look at this picture of me
and of your home
wall picture as well,
I would say that it reminds
me of a quote I saw somewhere,
which is, the darkness
that we experience
is not the darkness
of the tomb but rather
the darkness of the womb.
We are to be born.
We are to be awakened.
The fact that we are
doing this project,
experiencing these struggles,
and conflicts, and emotions
is the start of something
new and the start
of the liberation of all of us.
And so now I look
at these pictures
I feel extremely hopeful.
So for me it has been
the past three years
and the journey didn't
start with the project.
It was very well captured
with the project.
And it continued
after the project.
Thank you so much
Dodo for sharing that.
Of course.
It was amazing to hear.
Thank you inviting.
Yeah.
I'm so glad you could make it.
Now, Sarah, if you
want to take over.
Yeah, I was just
going to say I think
it's time that we can invite
everyone into the conversation.
You're welcome to
speak up, or to put
a question into the chat.
We welcome either
one and we love
to see videos on for friends and
family so Elaheh can see you.
Anyone who's got a question.
Can you hear me?
Yes, thanks.
Hi, I'm Moustafa, and I
have a question for Elaheh
or any other of the
participants here.
I've been seeing the
posters for the exhibition
on the social media and
that's the main reason
I joined the exhibition today.
And there's a question
growing in my mind
and that's why the dark
theme or the black color
is chosen to represent
the participants
in this exhibition.
What does exactly
this color means
and what emotion this color
is going to express there?
So I told everybody
to wear whatever
they're comfortable with.
So whatever, it's them.
For example, if I'm a person
that I usually wear dresses
and that's what
I'm comfortable in,
then I wanted the person
to wear the dress.
Or if they're usually
comfortable walking around
with jerseys then that's what
I wanted them to show up with.
And I think in the
final photo shoot
you can see that contrast
of what different women are
comfortable wearing and
feel like that's them.
That's what they are.
Thank you very much.
That was a great exhibition.
Yeah, of course,
thank you for joining.
I have a question
about your contribution
to the arts in your life at MIT.
Were you surprised by what
prominence this practice took
in your life as a student?
Was that something you expected
or was that a discovery
for you?
It was not something
that I expected.
It when I found--
so growing up, I knew
I loved photography.
I would always take
a photo on my phone
or steal my mom's camera
and take photos with that.
So I knew I liked it.
But I realized how powerful it
can be in my photography class.
Again, thanks to my
amazing professors
who opened my eyes
to the power of arts.
And that was then that I
realized the issues that I care
about, I probably can
contribute doing robotics
and the engineering that
I'm studying and I'm doing,
but I realize there
is like something
more powerful with
just like a photo.
That you can show it
to different people ,
everybody would take
something different from it,
and it's just so powerful
because there's like no right
or wrong, no this or that.
This is what I'm showing you.
I put a lot of emotions in it,
now what do you take out of it.
And I think that was
something that in photography
and the visual arts that
I started practicing,
I saw a lot more than I ever
saw in my engineering classes
or research.
That's a good answer, thanks.
Thank you, [INAUDIBLE].
Really interesting.
And since I'm here
to moderate, I
want to welcome anyone
else to ask a question.
You can also ask of
anyone who participated
who wants to speak up.
We'd love to hear from you.
Thank you Elaheh for your
invitation to the opening.
It's very brave of you to
express yourself so publicly.
My question for you is that, you
said that when you started it,
it was a personal project.
And then you realized that
other people were also
struggling with
issues and you started
to invite them to also
join this and feel
this experience with you.
So my question is
that, what made you
feel that the project was done?
Because it can go on forever.
And what made you
stop and decide that,
OK, it's time to wrap it up.
That's a good question.
I think it was a very
hard call to make.
I think one thing that
I realized in 2020,
before I actually make the
call of having the final photo
shoot, was that my goal was
to have a space for everybody
to feel safe.
And I felt like my
project maybe is also
creating some sort of
gender exclusiveness,
that I'm just
making it for women
to feel, to show the
struggles of women
and show the struggles
of female in the society.
And I realized I want
it to be more than that.
Even though yes, women have had
a lot of struggles in history,
we can just go and see how much
bias has affected all of us.
But the society that
we're living now,
we know that the gender
is not binary anymore.
We have non-binary
identification
and those people are also
having struggles of their own.
And it's just a wide range
of people and just people
having struggles.
And I wanted my
next project to be
more about that creating a
safer space for everybody.
Creating something
that everybody
can contribute to, and
have other audiences to see
that and be like, OK, we need
to be more cautious or conscious
of all of these issues and
we need to speak up about all
of these issues.
OK, thank you and do you
have anything in your mind
that you'd be proceeding
with your next project?
A future project.
That's a good question.
[LAUGHTER]
OK, sorry.
That's a good question.
That's my answer.
Fair enough.
I actually have
the same question
I was going to ask her, what are
you going to do with your time
now that a project has its
showcase and it's over?
Yeah, I know it's--
I'm going to sleep.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah, I'm going to
do a lot of that
and once I have a lot of sleep,
I'll think about something else
to do.
Do you think that
this project will
extend into your
professional life in any way?
Any of the lessons
that you've learned
go into your professional work?
I mean, obviously you're
finishing your degree still
and--
Yeah, I think so.
I think this project gave me
a lot of courage to just talk
to people as people.
Because I think
sometimes it's just hard
to see other people as
somebody else who's also
struggling and dealing
with everything
that you are also dealing with.
And I think doing this project
I would just go to people
and start talking
to them and be like,
Yeah, there is this
project that I'm working on
and it would just open
up the conversation
and help me get to know
people, connect to more people.
And I think that was a
practice for me to just learn
how to talk to people
because as somebody who
moved from Iran to US and
as somebody who's English
is my second language, it was
a challenge for me to just talk
to people when I
first moved to US.
And make friends and network, or
just in a party talk to people.
And I think this project
gave me a really good medium
in practice and I'm grateful.
Dodo has a question.
Yeah, so I guess
on a related topic,
how do you see arts, maybe
photography obviously
is a big part of it or
maybe other art forms,
play into your
life or profession?
Whether a professional
life or from this point on,
what is the role of
continuing to be an artist?
What does that mean to you?
What's your plan around that?
That's a really great question.
These are actually things that
I'm actively thinking about.
What am I going to do next?
How is this going to merge
with my engineering life?
And the honest answer is
that I still don't know.
I'm still trying
to figure it out.
But some ideas
that I have now is
that I really enjoy talking
to different people.
Bringing different people from
different backgrounds together
and having them connect
and have something amazing
come out of it.
And I think I want to use
that to bring people together.
Whether it's going to be
an engineering project,
an art project, or something
completely different.
But I want to bring
people together.
Because when I talk to
people individually,
I can see how amazing
they are and sometimes I
can see how they're
not confident
and they don't see
how amazing they are.
And I want to be
like, if I can, I
want to be able to tell
them that you're amazing.
And then tell
somebody else who I
know it's amazing be
like, you two are awesome,
meet each other, make
something amazing.
And I think I could do a
little bit of that in Trapped
and I want to do more of that.
All right, cool, yeah.
I can relate.
I think that's the power of arts
in that case is very strong.
Thank you.
Yeah, thank you for asking me.
I'd say the world needs you.
No.
Needs more of that.
Anyone else?
Hi, Elaheh.
This is really great.
Thank you for sharing
these pictures with us,
and also thanks for inviting me.
I have one more question
for you I wanted to ask.
For people wondering
or people debating
considering incorporating
art into their other non art
professional lives, or other
things, what advice would
you have for these
people wanting
to pursue art in addition to
anything else that you do?
Given that you have been able
to do it very successfully.
Thank you for saying that.
I think what I tell myself
is that if there is something
that you want to do, do it.
If you want to take a day
out of your crazy schedule
and just go out and
take photos, just do it.
And we all need a
time, need a break,
we all need a way to express
everything that's building up.
And I feel like with
our lives now, it's
everything happening
back to back
and you don't have a
time to process anything.
You don't have a time to sit
back and see what is happening.
And art for most of us
is a way to take out
all of the things that
have been piling up
in our bodies and our
mind and just get it out.
And we need that, you need that
as a way to stay sane and be
able to operate in
your crazy life.
So if you have something
that makes you happy, do it.
Even if you think it's going
to take up from your life
and keep you from doing
your PSATs, or research,
or whatever.
It's not because it's going to
help you take everything that's
in your mind out and then you
can focus on the other parts
more too because you
will have a clear mind
and that will help you the 100%.
If it didn't, come find me.
I will be responsible.
OK, thanks for that.
Thank you for asking me.
I will probably add something.
If you have time,
go model for Elaheh.
It helps your self-confidence.
Yeah, it really does.
I am really
uncomfortable in photos.
I am really uncomfortable
and just Elaheh
taking two or three random
or casual pictures of me.
I felt the confidence boost.
Yeah.
She's great.
You can't separate
her from this project.
She's a very big
part of this idea.
It's not easy as--
at least I don't think
I'm not a photographer,
but I don't think it's
easy as a photographer
to make someone comfortable
that you're taking photos of
and Elaheh is so good at that.
She's so good at that.
Thank you for your
amazing music too.
Thanks.
For those who didn't know,
the music in the movie
and in the opening
was composed by Aria.
And it was amazing.
Composed.
Yeah, It was some random
improvises, but thanks.
[INAUDIBLE] is also here, right?
Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE] was the designer
of the exhibition, what
you're about to
see, and thank you
so much for making that happen.
I tried to like change
one or two things
that I was going crazy.
So thank you so much
for making that happen.
Of course, thank you for
all the beautiful art.
I had such a good
time making it,
to the point where I'm probably
going to be making more artist
websites.
That was amazing.
Thank you.
I'm super proud of you.
I'm glad you had a good time.
So we've got some really lively
and inspiring conversation
happening.
I want to encourage
that to keep going on,
but I'm also being
sensitive to the hour.
So I think we're going to
wrap up the official event
and we're going to thank
everybody for joining us.
Thank you so much to
Elaheh for this fantastic
showing of Trapped.
On that subject we'd like
to encourage everybody
in here to visit the
Wiesner gallery site
and to explore this exhibition
and others at your leisure.
And basically, I
think at this point,
we can move into the
after hours segment.
So if you are friends, family,
peers, colleagues, anybody
and you want to stick
around and chat with Elaheh
and with each other, we're
going to keep this room open.
Feel free to yourselves
and let the party continue.
Thank you all for coming today.
Yes, thank you all so much.
Have an awesome evening.
Thank you.
I also want to
thank everybody who
joined me and joined us today.
I really hope you
enjoyed the exhibition
and if you have time let's stick
around and talk, share stories.